so what is the difference quotient well
you can see difference means subtracting
quotient means dividing and this is the
formula here it's f of X plus h minus f
of X all over H and this is starting to
get into some calculus this video is
intending more for precalculus students
but basically what you have here is you
have here is ax and here's the point f
of X on the this curve region right here
if you go a little distance to the right
we're going to call that distance H that
puts you over here at X plus h and if
you go up to the curve that y-coordinate
is f of X plus h now if we use our slope
formula our slope formula is y2 ok so y2
minus y1 over x2 minus x1 here you can
see the X's are going to cancel one
another out that's where this difference
quotient comes from over here and then
what happens is if you take the limit
okay as H approaches zero meaning has
this distance between this point and
this point gets smaller and smaller this
point moves along the curve until these
points they coincide with one another
and so what happens is instead of
getting this average rate of change the
secant line right here you're actually
getting the instantaneous rate of change
okay which is the slope at that point
here so we're using the slope formula
but we're using limits to bring these
points closer together until they
coincide and then we get the
instantaneous rate of change that's the
slope at this point here but we're going
to talk about here is just how to work
with finding the difference quotient and
all it really is is a substitution so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take whatever is in the parentheses here
X plus h that's going to go in place of
X on the right side of the equation so
what this looks like is if we put X plus
h into our function we get X plus h the
quantity squared plus 3 okay that's this
part right here minus f of X which is
this entire
function here - x squared plus three
can't put it in parentheses so we treat
it as a group all divided by H okay and
then this is the limit as H approaches
zero now all we're going to do is we're
just going to do some arithmetic and
simplify this down so what we get is x
squared plus two HX plus h squared plus
three minus x squared minus three
because you have to distribute the
negative okay all divided by H now you
can see we've got some cancellation
occurring here we have X Squared's
cancel the threes cancel and we're left
with 2h X plus h squared divided by H we
could factor out an H so we have 2x plus
H divided by H the H is cancel this is
our final result but if we want to take
the limit as H approaches zero we can
substitute 0 in for H here and we're
gonna get two acts so what the 2x means
is that okay if we were to look at this
graph y equals x squared plus three one
two three it's a parabola like this okay
this is a formula for the slope anywhere
along this curve so for example if we go
over here to x equals one and we go up
to the to the function there two times
one is two that means the instantaneous
rate of change here the slope at that
point is going to be to say we put a
negative one we go up to the curve
that's going to have a slope of negative
two so this is the formula you just want
to memorize the difference quotient and
all it is again is just a substitution
you're putting X plus h in for X okay
and simplifying and you're subtracting f
of X which is the original function and
then again simplifying so this has been
a introduction into how to find the
difference quotient and it's
applications in calculus I'll see you in
the next video